que ce soit pour des insertions
professionnelles ou des chantiers
bénévoles l'association études et
chantiers propose depuis 2001 des
projets collectifs d'intérêt général
dans 80 pays
comme c'est le cas sur ce chantier de
rénovation des glacières du château de
pain seul ou à son chant ya plusieurs
branches fia et les espaces verts la
maçonnerie
il faut également un atelier vélo on
voit là dans un but écologique qu'on est
là pour justement réhabiliter un petit
peu le terrain donc pour faire du
nettoyage pour redonner vie un peu à ces
monuments historiques
oui mais c est bien faisait jadis par
action soutenu par le pnr de la vallée
de chevreuse ce chantier bénévole
mélange des jeunes adultes du monde
entier autour d'un véritable travail d
équipe on a des japonais on l'avait
mexicain on a des espagnols des
allemands des tur que les pakistanais et
je n'ai peut-être rien oui mon cas je
suis désolé mais beaucoup c'est vraiment
cosmopolite c'est vraiment une mixité
richesse culturelle sinon c'est vraiment
génial et c'est donc par ce mélange
d'origines dans un travail collectif que
se crée des liens puissants entre les
différents participants tout en leur
faisant découvrir de nombreuses cultures
c'est vraiment des jeunes qui
participent énormément
ils sont volontaires ils travaillent
vraiment bien j'ai rien à dire c'est une
superbe équipe pour des gens qui ne sont
pas du tout du métier en plus donc c'est
assez vraiment agréable à vivre
ouvert à tous de 14 à 99 ans sans
condition de diplôme de compétence ou de
niveau de langue
ces chantiers sont de véritables
expériences de vie mêlant insertion
professionnelle et rencontres le tout
dans une ambiance très conviviale